what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here today john how's
your day john's day is all right all
right people looks like we got someone
here william hurt
william is back from the dead he's
coming to apologize
those controversies caught up with them
finally will smith uh finally speaking
up we want to hear what he has to say
fascinating seeing this you know i was
actually watching the david letterman
interview that was shot before the
academy awards from my guest needs no
introduction that netflix series and it
was just interesting watching it because
i'm like yeah that's the the
inspirational words of wisdom will smith
just interested in looking at like
what's happened with his career as a
label we'll see what he has to say how
heavily produced this is
that's going to be the most high gloss
apology video
he's joining the list of youtubers
apologizing
[Music]
what if it was like i haven't thought
about this at all
cleared my mind
why didn't you apologize to chris in
your acceptance speech
um good question yeah
i was fogged out by that point
it's it's it's it's all fuzzy i've
reached out to
chris um
and the mesh the message that came back
is that uh he's not ready to talk
and when he is
he will
reach out
um um
okay that's fair so i will i will say to
you
um chris
i
apologize
to you
my behavior
was
unacceptable
and i'm here
whenever you're ready to talk
um
i i want to apologize to chris's mother
i saw an interview yeah
saw that too and
you know that was one of the things
about that moment i just didn't realize
and you know i wasn't thinking but how
many people got hurt in that moment
right so that's just about you apologize
to chris's mother i want to apologize to
uh chris's family uh specifically tony
rock you know we had a great
relationship yeah you know when hearing
this one of the first things that comes
to mind is there's this whole side of
this whole thing that's like do we
forgive will smith and then the big
question is is well actually what does
chris rock forgive will smith that's
like probably the most important
question i know chris rock was speaking
recently and i know in like our past
videos we've even talked about i'm sure
chris rock is not gonna go around saying
i'm a victim i'm a victim of this and
i'm sure enough that's what he said he's
like
i'm not a victim in this situation yeah
yeah the bottom line is does that mean
he has forgiven will smith you know one
exactly was this shot this specific
video that is probably the first and
foremost
most important thing before we forgive
it yeah yeah everybody involved should
work this out it doesn't really matter
what the rest of us think in terms of my
like honest opinion about the situation
i can move past it you know chris rock
does why can't i and i don't even need
chris rock too to be totally frank with
you i like i can move fast you know i'm
sure many of us
can too unless it was extremely
sensitively triggering for you in your
own personal ways but for me it just
wasn't yeah unless it becomes like a
chronic thing i mean it depends on the
kind of work will smith is doing but it
certainly seems like he's taken time to
measure this response we can acknowledge
what happened probably let him out of
movie jail pretty soon just because yeah
it's a human moment and it doesn't seem
indicative of some kind of toxic streak
of like this guy's got to go and be
violent with everybody you know tony
rock was my man um
and uh this is this is probably
irreparable
um
i spent the last
three months
replaying
and
understanding the nuances and and the
complexity
of what happened
in in that moment
um
and
i'm not going to try to unpack all of
that right now but i can say to
all of you there is no part of me
that thinks that was the right way
to
behave
in that moment
there's no part of me that thinks that's
the optimal way
to
handle
a feeling of disrespect or or insults
after jada rolled her eyes did she tell
you to do something
no um
it's like
you know i'm i made a choice
on my own
from my own experiences from
my
history with chris jada had nothing to
do with it
i'm sorry babe
um
i'm gonna say sorry to my my kids and
my family
for the heat that i brought on
all of us yeah
i think that was probably the most
annoying part to me about this whole
ordeal how jada became the scapegoat for
will smith's decision i know a lot of
people will come at me or come in here
being like oh you know if you're in a
talks relationship that emotionally
abusive and then it does something to a
man and i'm like sure bottom line is
he's a grown ass man who made his own
choice and went up there on that stage
took the time to walk up there nah she
forced it yeah but a lot of people think
yeah it's a freaking like emperor
palpatine
do it
like that's not what the reality is
let's say they have like a terrible
relationship it was still his choice
bottom line and then there were a lot of
like articles and people trying to make
it like that was all completely her
fault i'm like yeah i'm solving will
completely no that was that was that was
probably the most frustrating part yeah
that speaks to something else toxic in
our society to all my fellow nominees
you know this is a community it's like i
won because you you voted for me and it
really breaks my heart to have stolen
and and harnessed tarnished your moment
um
i can still see
quest loves wow eyes you know it it
happened on quest love's
award and
i feel so bad you know
it's like i'm i'm
i'm sorry really is it
sufficient
what would you say to the people who
looked up to you
before the slap or people who expressed
that you let them down
so there's two things one
disappointing people is my central
trauma
um i hate
when
i let people down
um so
it
it hurts
uh it hurts me psychologically and
emotionally to know i didn't live up to
uh people's
image and impression of me
and
the work i'm trying to do is
i am
deeply remorseful
and i'm trying to be remorseful without
being ashamed of myself
right i'm human and
i made
a mistake
and
i'm trying not to think of myself as a
piece of [ __ ]
um
so i would say to those people i know
it was confusing i know it was shocking
um
but i i promise you
i am
uh deeply devoted and committed to
putting light and love and joy
into the world
and
you know
if you if you hang on i promise we'll be
able to be friends again that was one of
the biggest takeaways for me in this
situation because uh like many i'm
someone who had absorbed so much of will
smith speaking countless variety of
interviews when it came to you know
either be motivational talk like i said
words of wisdom personal development
there's a lot of psychological insight
into work ethic or goal setting or life
skills it impacts on a way that feels so
disappointing you know like there are
certain people that if they did
something like this you wouldn't be like
oh that is
shocking because that action makes you
kind of look back and question you know
a lot of like what is
the truth you know do i question now can
i just take the advice still to heart of
everything he's ever spoken about but he
does speak on something very true with
you know it's like when you make a
mistake a lot of times you want to kind
of put on this display of of shame
because if you feel like just terrible
and you really show it like maybe that's
the way to get people to forgive you but
living in a cycle of shame will they
only make it worse and in fact that
wouldn't allow someone to progress to a
level where they can heal emotionally
and mentally to the point where they
wouldn't do something like this again
because that's the issue when you live
in the emotions of shame you know
there's guilt and then there's shame now
it's temporary shame i totally can't but
you do got to get to a point so what
he's speaking about is a really hard
place to find and i'm curious if he if
he actually is there where you are
genuinely like i am very remorseful and
i got to live with that but also i gotta
still improve myself because if you're
stuck in shame you're just not gonna
improve because you're gonna be kind of
convinced then that that's who you are
and that's what you do is these things
that you are ashamed of or that are
destructive when really yeah it's about
letting go of some of that so that you
can you know embrace the good and
enhance the good within you step beyond
that moment of weakness and come to some
kind of you know strong conclusion you
can't be
so down the shameful that you can't just
look at the situation for what it is and
then learn what you need to learn from
that and i think that's a thing that a
lot of people struggle to struggle with
as well generally i mean i struggle with
that you know uh you know not
you
should be in shame you know you're right
though all the time yeah i know if
anyone knows everything i just said
person
does not apply to john here stupid screw
up all the time on purpose
you think this is a bit
this is just how we greet each other
best of luck to will smith i hope him
and chris rock and resolve what i'm
really waiting for is a hilarious
stand-up special from chris rock where
he talks about the slap the slapping
that's what you know full hours
you know that's what's coming and we
gotta get that going and then maybe they
can laugh about it and will smith will
greet him backstage and talk to him and
dave chappelle it'll be a great time
i'll do an awkward oscars bit about it
next year
the fake slap scenario all right guys
well william smith is back
bad boys for life
leave your thoughts we'll talk to you
soon
[Music]